the fascinating thing about this
final-season is that we're asking a very
big question about power and and I think
that this season has gone far and beyond
who's sitting on the throne it's bigger
than that
the discussion is what we're bringing to
the table is bigger than that's right hi
everyone is Charlie TV guy just did a
preview of Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 so we have to break it down
the producers Dan and Dave said some
really interesting things about the
finale to that I'll go through but the
actors give a lot of really good
information confirm a couple big plot
points and we learned about a special
bonus episode that they're gonna air
after the finale that I'll explain I'll
be doing Game of Thrones videos all
season long so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a new round of the
book giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I just broke this
down top 10 style I don't really
consider any of this stuff spoilery
because this is all official information
that HBO released through TV guides so
starting with number 10
George R Martin says that the ending of
the show is based on broad plot points
that he gave to Anand Dave years ago so
the really really big parts of the TV
shows ending will be the same as the
ending of the books and dream of spring
but obviously there's a whole bunch of
characters that are alive in the books
that are dead on the TV show there are a
whole bunch of extra characters that the
TV show never did so the way they get
there and what those final scenes look
like will be a little bit different even
though largely the same mechanics will
be going on in Dan and Dave also like I
said gave a couple quotes about the
story of the last couple of episodes
I'll talk about that in a second - but
number 9 the special bonus episode we
considered episode 7 but technically
it's a two-hour documentary called the
last watch if you've ever watched any of
HBO's documentary films about anything
any subject it'll be just like that but
about Game of Thrones it'll air on HBO
May 26 one week after the finale so if
it were just the next episode after the
finale Emilia Clarke talks about what
happens to Daenerys when she learns Jon
Snow's her older brother Rhaegar
Targaryen son she says when they
discovered the truth she ends up in an
incredibly fragile place John is her
only safety left then Kit Harington
popped up and said an incest isn't
exactly straight-laced John's style he's
not the kind of person who can knowing
jump into bed with a relative there was
this preview image of season 8 episode 2
she still looks like she's relatively
happy so this seems like it was taken
before she finds out there's a shot in
the trailer where you see her in one of
her rooms in Winterfell just looking
really sad and really bummed out pretty
safe bet that this is after she finds
out
but like Emilia Clarke says John is
Daenerys his last safety net so she
probably still wants to be with him he
still wants to be with her
he's just having problems with the
Targaryen wedding sister to brother of
it all
because if you remember in the books
Daenerys is actually thinking about her
marriages to all these different people
in her relationship with her brother
Viserys she says that before she married
Khal Drogo she actually expected that
she would wind up marrying her brother
Viserys so even though the TV show ages
the actors up a little bit in the books
Daenerys is about 13 years old when she
marries Khal Drogo at age 13 she was
already totally okay marrying her older
brother so even though there's only a
couple episodes it's not like they're
gonna drag this out for forever if
anyone's gonna win anyone over in this
weird relationship of theirs it's
probably gonna be Daenerys trying to
make John understand how it's okay it's
even part of their family's customs but
then on the other side of their
relationship is Tyrion who's kind of
like a brood mother the first couple of
episodes at least around the two of them
he says that he's worried that the
fallout from their relationship is
basically gonna kill the Northern
Alliance before the White Walkers attack
Peter Dinklage's quote about Tyrion just
says he understands the potential danger
for everyone if their relationship goes
south so there's a little bit of that
going on in the background there's also
the interview that Peter Dinklage did
last year when he was talking about
Tyrion being smitten with Daenerys as he
has romantic interest in her in a little
bit of that jealousy was also clouding
his judgment so I don't know how thick
they're gonna lay that on because given
Tyrians character in his shift the last
couple of seasons that feels like them
including drama just for the sake of
drama like I've no point during season
six or even if the early parts of season
seven did I get a feeling that Tyrion
had any romantic ideas about Daenerys he
just seemed like he was happy to serve
her and at times trying to manage her
like the conversations that he had with
Varys where they said we need to find a
way to make Daenerys listen to our
advice that was the big things they were
worried about they confirm all the big
characters that are gonna be there in
the courtyard at Winterfell during the
season eight episode one introduction
scene where Jon Snow is introducing
daenerys to Sansa so also present in
this moment but just off of camera is
Arya Stark bran Stark is in the
courtyard Varys tyrion insert Jorah is
there they don't mention anything about
Gendry Jaime Lannister or bronze so they
probably show up somewhere else during
the episode Jaime it actually seems in
the trailer might even be down at the
twins because the twins are like the
last really big defensible position
between Winterfell and the southern
kingdoms the White Walkers can't cross
big bodies of water so the twins would
be a really important location for them
next one's actually kind of unexpected
they say the brand has gained the
ability during season eight to glimpse
the future on a limited basis so why is
it Hempstead right a little while ago
confirmed that bran was getting better
at using his abilities and he was better
able to interact with people so he
wasn't gonna be as much of a turnip the
scene where he's talking to Sam will
imagine like a much bigger more
articulate version of that the only way
that they describe it in the article
though is that he can see the past
president in glimpses of the future so
that is a really really big power so a
while ago when the actor who plays the
night king named Vladimir fur 'dick said
that the night King has a target a very
specific target that we'll find out
about during season eight
my first thought that it would be brand
because he's the most powerful person
that would have all the information that
they need to stop the night King if
brain is that much of a threat to him he
would want to neutralize that and also
glimpsing the future is another easy way
to close the series down and give you a
jump forward to show you what happens to
all the characters that survive so we've
been talking about Daenerys potentially
getting pregnant with Jon Snow's child
they wouldn't have to jump forward Lord
of the Ring style the show could just
use brands glimpses of the future to
show you what that baby looks like
because the only other way to do that
would be to jump nine months into the
future at the very end of the show which
is kind of weird so just think about all
the other things that they could use
that ability for short term they could
use it to try and see the battle to try
and defeat the knight Cain trying to
feed Cersei down in King's Landing but I
think the flash-forwards would be more
important for implying what's gonna be
happening in the future of these
characters lives way down the road let
me know in the comments though what
other big things do you think that
they're gonna pay off in the future
using brands visions
next one sophie turner talks a little
bit more about her relationship with Jon
Snow and Daenerys initially she talks
about Sansa feeling threatened sophie
Turner's quote is is she worked so hard
to control the No
and it feels like Jon's should be loyal
it's frustrating to have Daenerys who
Sansa feels like is manipulating John
come in and take her control
so obviously big power play of course
there's gonna be a bit of a gunslinger
standoff when they meet each other they
also implied that the reunion that Arya
has with John won't be quite what you
expect like don't expect them to run
into each others arms because there's a
lot of you have probably figured out and
what Maisie Williams says about it is
that she's changed so much since she was
that little girl way back during season
1 episode 2 the last time they embraced
so a lot of her emotional journey this
season is in trying to reconcile the
woman that she's become and the person
that she wanted to be when she was a
little girl 3 Maisie Williams also
specifically mentioned Cersei when
talking about her list so the list is
still very much a thing during season 8
just remember that because I think it'll
be much more important towards the end
of the season than it is at the
beginning of the season but of course
Lena Headey talked about what's going on
with Cersei at the beginning of season 8
episode 1
she said that Cersei is scared but she
stays in her safety lane which is
survival in a brave front so if you
remembered Cersei in the book she slowly
starts to lose her mind starting I think
we're on feast for crows they've also
changed a lot of other core elements
about her plotline so we're kind of in
uncharted territory plot wise with
Cersei but Lena Headey did another
interview where she talked about Cersei
being in a prison of sorts of her own
making like she builds this box for
herself that she has trouble getting out
of I think she's mostly referring to her
relationship with Euron and his role is
a very simple straight-up bad guy in
that situation they want Cersei to be
very complex villain so on a smaller
level you're on in the iron bank are
gonna be two things that Cersei will
have to deal with at the beginning of
the season biggest thing though Dan and
Dave talk about the story of the last
couple of episodes they say there have
been crimes committed on all sides and
whether the characters are able to
reconcile in some way or if the friction
the fuse continued that's one of the
major issues were going to see unfold
they also refer to Daenerys his ideas
about breaking the wheel they actually
refer to John is a very tried and true
steady leader old school in Daenerys as
the sort of new idea that she's going to
completely dismantle the power structure
of Westeros break the wheel and
potential foreshadowing of literally
breaking the Iron Throne like getting
rid of the thing that everyone's so
focused on like Emilia Clarke
in the interview at the beginning of the
video is so much bigger than the actual
throne itself the way they talked about
it actually almost sounds exactly like
the events that followed Aegon's
conquest what happened in the books is
that after Aegon's conquest of the six
kingdoms because he didn't conquer Dorne
he had to spend the rest of his life
going all over the place
because there were continued minor
skirmishes in all the different realms
so even though he quote/unquote
conquered the kingdom it still took the
better part of another hundred years
before things settled down so even if
Jon Snow and Daenerys win the Iron
Throne it's still gonna be a really big
battle for them going forward because
not everybody's gonna be really happy
with Daenerys his ideas we only got a
couple weeks before a game of Thrones
comes back there'll be a big media blitz
oh they'll be more footage dropping so
leave your requests in the comments
below
congratulations iron hand you're the
giveaway winner from my last big game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here to learn about
all the big callbacks in the season a
trailer for scenes from the Game of
Thrones pilot episode and click here for
my Game of Thrones Season 8 golden
company video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight